did not get any sleep I pulled my hair
out Wednesday Adams can handle pretty
much anything I've been hunted haunted
and mimicked millions of times across
the Internet it's been pure torture
but for Jenna Ortega training to become
the titular character of Netflix's hit
series came with a price which she
explained during a q a event in
Hollywood I did not get any sleep I
pulled my hair out there's so many
FaceTime calls that my dad answered of
me hysterically crying
um and then I remember Tim being uh
don't worry you're gonna do great it's
gonna look great yeah the 20 year old
actress admits learning Wednesday's
skill set wasn't easy fencing speaking
German
[Music]
and playing cello
it was shoot you know show up to set two
hours early do the 12 14 hour day then
go home and then get on a zoom and have
whatever lesson that I had or had
whatever cello lesson that I would choke
to my apartment and My Cello teacher was
already waiting for me it was like that
sort of thing where it was just
constantly going then if you could on a
weekend if we weren't shooting the sixth
day that week it was the all right well
then we'll get your lessons in on that
day it was a lot I I started cello and
fencing a couple months before we
started production and then I I
continued throughout the the eight
months of shooting in Romania sounds
grueling but clearly all that hard work
paid off Jenna's performance is a
favorite amongst fans and critics she
even earned Golden Globe and sag Award
nominations
and if you're looking for more Wednesday
wackiness you're in luck
the kooky and spooky show has officially
been renewed for season two it just felt
appropriate and in true Wednesday
fashion Jenna had the best in-character
reaction to the news honestly I wish I
cared a little more would you hope to
explore in a possible second season I
kind of want her to be darker
I want her to get more in the
nitty-gritty of things and not play
things so safe because there's a lot of
lines this one about her ah it's just
saving the school and doing whatever but
for me her main drive with the monster
was kind of a competitiveness kind of
man how's this guy doing this so I think
I think I wanted to I want to continue
down an anti-hero stream rather than
typical hero as for Hunter Duhan who
plays Wednesday's love interest Tyler
he's got some ideas about where his
character goes next now that his secret
is out I'm excited for season two to
kind of explore him fighting between the
monster and the real version of him and
also he doesn't have his master
Christina Ricci anymore so what's he
gonna be like I don't know and while
fans anxiously wait for Netflix to drop
season two you guys are making me
nauseous
not in a good way we'll be over here
crossing our fingers Jenna gets a little
more rest this time around
[Music]